I give away more than yours
- my man mahalo keep Jenny from
black/pink fellow citizens of one hey
another powerful little sister Zhu Jie I
will never forget about you wait this is
not enough who's the best rapper in the
bunch why was Shady
definitely tagging honestly say it wraps
presents the best he's very like she's
perfect I want everything she does you
know okay not like that I think the best
rapper is a I'm in Tecate B and who do
you think is the worst weapon
Milius the worst rapper
[Music]
I think the worst of wrapping Christmas
presents is me but in a good way because
I do it fast and efficient I don't waste
my time doing it one by one I just throw
them all in and then I wrap it right
away trapping do you know what I'm
talking about
it's the best it's also me because I do
it very well
Candice do a little improv no search on
the corner I like to just wish everyone
happy holidays for Christmas for
Hanukkah or Kwanzaa whatever you want
happy holidays happy holidays Happy
Holidays Happy Holidays happy holidays
[Music]
you